[Musique]
j'aime c'est notre robot qu'on a
construit ici en 2013 2014
c'est un robot humanoïde
mais d'ailleurs un peu différent des
autres humanoïdes qu'on voit
présentement dans la recherche de
robotique chine a été construit basé sur
une compétition que la défense
américaine mis sur pied il ya eu un
désastre au japon en 2011 à fukushima et
puis ils ont réalisé après le désastreux
si j'avais pu envoyer quelqu'un ou
quelque chose pour ouvrir une valve pour
permettre un liquide de refroidissement
d'atteindre le le réacteur il aurait pu
complètement arrêter le désastre avant
qu'il arrive donc basé sur sa la défense
américaine dark pop a décidé à réaliser
comme nous n'étions pas prêts en tant
que communauté pour répondre à nos un
autre événement de cette envergure
donc ils ont mis sur pied cette
compétition et donc il y avait 23
équipes qui se sont inscrits pour
compétitionner donc hachey a réussi à
faire toutes les tâches en moins de 60
minutes seulement trois équipes sur le
métro a réussi à faire de cet argent